i think it's i use the ecological model
in understanding how wisdom traditions
ought to work in the world today and the
ecologic ecological model we need every
single species we don't know which steep
species that's going to be extinct was
actually going to be central in figuring
out something that would enhance our
lives on this planet well I consider
with ancient religious wisdom traditions
much like species we don't know which
ones are contributing exactly what to
the unfolding of and the development of
human beings on this planet and the
greatness of this moment the greatness
of for America the unbelievable freedom
and and openness and permeability of at
least intellectual and spiritual
boundaries the greatness of the
technology that now allows us to to
speak across every institutional and
dogmatic and theological barrier every
single one if we want the greatness is
people can bring their wares you know
their wisdom to the marketplace and I
not only mark the place in the low level
but in to the intellectual and spiritual
tables that that everyone can die not
and and we need them all and because you
don't know which resource and which tool
you need when in your life and I
understand the danger in that the danger
is everybody to become a tourist and
being a tourist is different than living
somewhere and that's different than
being a pilgrim and it's different than
being a pioneer but each of us have our
psychological and spiritual
predispositions towards being in the
world in different ways and and the
opportunity of this moment is to bring
our wisdoms everyone I don't care if
you're an imam or a priest or a minister
or to bring your spiritual where's
practices and wisdom to the marketplace
to the public culture to the public
arena and offer it and what's great
about this kind of freedom is it's it's
a phenomenal test to see if your wisdom
works for most of human history
religious wisdom was was offered in very
parochial monopolistic and and
controlling ways in other words if I had
a Jewish practice of
if let's say being kosher and some
community of the member didn't do that
you could ostracize that member it was
amazing how fast that person became
kosher it's not clear that's the best
way to use a religious practice and was
true in Judaism's true in every other
religion now actually the practices and
the methods and the stories and the
narratives they have to work and work is
very simple after you try this practice
for 30 days after you study the story
and and whether it's a biblical story or
a Talmudic story or if I'm a Christian a
New Testament story or a church by the
story after you study the story after
you try this practice tell me you
witness yourself are you a little more
self-aware any of the distortions any of
the ways in which we fool ourselves any
of the illusions any of them kind of
loosen a little bit and are you any more
compassionate and loving and empathetic
if yes you found a practice that may
work for now and if not either retool
the practice play with it a little bit
because that's the authority we have in
this world right now as individuals or
go find another practice and that's
incredible moment of its scary for all
religions and that's why some religions
are freaking out right now but it's an
unbelievable cleansing moment because
now we're going to have evidence-based
spirituality only evidence-based
medicine now we're going to have
evidence-based spirituality here's the
practice here's the wisdom try it
meditate on it reflect on it
contemplated use it does it work fine
not then you know what it's not to make
it
well first I think that everybody has to
figure out you always have to figure out
what your role in the in the system is
it's very easy to be completely
overwhelmed by a large big macro
question like how do we affect what
seems to be the world falling apart most
people can't affect the question at that
level of influence and the worst thing
to do is then to actually be paralyzed
by one's own powerlessness so I would
say the first thing everyone has to do
is to understand they're not as powerful
as they fantasize everybody from a
person in the street all the way to
whoever is the most powerful person on
the planet today you are not as powerful
as you fantasize about and you are not
as powerless as your nightmares now with
that helps do everybody has to think
about that what that helps a person
understand is Oh what is the real power
I have to effect within my radar screen
within my environment the world becoming
a little better not a lot better because
that's hubris not transforming the world
because people who try to transform the
world wind up killing a lot of people
even if they're trying to transform the
world in good ways so it's figuring out
where you we each can make the
contribution and and that's actually not
small because at least what my wisdom
tradition teaches and but I think this
is true of all wisdom traditions is each
of us is a microcosm of the entire world
that one person is of infinite value and
that means that if you're an infinite
value if you're of infinite value you
are worth everything and another person
is worth infinite value so when you
affect an upgrade and enhance and and
care for in a compassionate to one
person it does have a profound ripple
effect now that's not an excuse to
escape from using phones to maybe help
two people or 10 people or effect if we
can aren't businesses or our communities
it's knowing your space what you
actually can
and then really being this is it's it's
very very true that it's very
traditional being the very best person
you can be in that space and that's hard
because that's from from you know when
you come home in the evening after
working a long day and you walk into the
house and you know you want to go see
the mail first but actually maybe you
should say hello to your kids first or
or maybe you should kiss your spouse or
or kiss your lover hello first before
you do that because if you don't you
could a kind of distortion and hurt
which then you know carries over for the
next 50 years so it's every single act
something they think of it this way
imagine life is a giant scale you know
one's own life as a giant scale and
every single act from the smallest to
the grandest tips the scale either
towards life and compassion or a little
bit away now I know murdering someone is
really takes it away and and being able
to feed a million people really moves it
towards life but every single act tips
the scale and I think we all need to in
our own lives first become a little bit
more evolved and conscious of the power
of individual
oh you know I don't know I what impact
does my life have in the world what my
work have in the world I try not to ask
that question too often because you know
the world's a really big place you know
I don't know I yesterday I got a letter
is just yesterday I got a letter from a
23 year old in prison prison the prisons
in Colorado somewhere he writes dear
rabbi and it's a seven page handwritten
letter because I guess they don't have
computers in the prison dear rabbi and
he describes how he grew up in Colorado
and and you know whatever problem home
and he became a drug dealer and drug
addict and he got arrested and he he got
two and a half to ten years and about a
year ago he's been in jail about two
years about eight months ago a year ago
he says he began to realize that he had
allowed his life to get out of control
and somehow he got a copy of my book in
prison and he read the book and he
begins quoting pieces of the book on how
they've helped them out in his life in
the last eight months and he's writing
me knowing there's no way I'm going to
respond because I'm gonna think he's
crazy and and and anyway why should i
respond to him he's just a kid in prison
but he wanted me to know that what he
was doing was one he was recovering his
Jewish roots but then he quotes a
passage from the book about being open
to other people's spiritual insights
intuitions and wisdom because
spirituality is not a zero-sum game and
if I borrow someone else's practice or
learn from someone else I don't become
less of who I am I become more of who I
am and he quotes that past he says he's
become this kind of spiritual guide in
prison because he's willing to take the
partial truths from everybody and he
just wanted me to know that now I get
letters like that all the time you know
and and I mean that one's a particularly
intense letter cuz imagine this kid in
prison
and I think the impact the real impact
you have you never know the impact that
you can judge immediately is usually not
such important impact it's a short-term
impact I know we like bottom lines in
this country we like quarterly you know
profit statements but actually if you do
it quarter by quarter it's amazing how
the company very often goes under in the
long term I think the real changes we
want or one in our own selves to become
a little bit better and a little more
self-aware and then use that whatever
our talents are can do it as a as a
teacher can do it as a as a as a
sanitation man is a teacher as a mother
as a father as a brother you can do it
anywhere to use the talents to to simply
try to be help people become a little
bit more secure and a little bit better
and then you don't know the implications
changing one person and helping one
person could a decade later 20 years it
could be the person who actually cures
cancer and we have to begin to have at
least in the spiritual dimension I
understand corporate profits but in the
spiritual dimension you know we talked
to me much longer